This simplifies to x squared- 4.
This one is kind of tricky because now
we're subtracting some of the terms and
adding some of the terms.
Especially if you're going to be
rearranging terms before combining them,
it might be helpful to think of this
kind of problem as adding positive and
negative terms.
So we can rewrite the expression as x
squared + 3x + negative
9 + negative 3x + 5.
Now this will be a little
easier to rearrange.
We can see that 3x and
negative 3x are like terms, and
they can be written next to each other.
And negative 9 and
5 are also like terms.
So they can be written
next to each other too.
And then x squared can just stay as it
is because it doesn't have any other
like terms.
And what we're left with is 3x +
negative 3x + negative 9 + 5 + x
squared.
Combining 3x and negative 3x, we get 0x.
And then 0 times anything is 0.
So really, that's just 0.
And then combining negative 9 and
5, we get negative 4.
Keep our addition sign, and then bring
down the x squared because that doesn't
have anything to combine with.
We shouldn't include a 0, and so
we should rewrite this as
negative 4 + x squared.
Or it can be written as X squared- 4
if we don't want a negative in front.
Note that in a simplified
expression we don't include zeros
whether we're adding a zero, subtracting
a zero or multiplying by zero.